[Musique]
circulez a pris pour les habitants de
tokyo eux aussi la forme d'une aventure
quotidienne à l'intention de ces
malheureux piéton aux prises avec
quelques 400 mille véhicules
on a récemment installé un système de
panneaux lumineux indiquant seconde
après seconde
le maigre laps de temps restant pour
traverser sans danger
[Musique]
moyennant ces signaux moyennant aussi
les pédales à déclenchement automatique
les piétons de tokyo peuvent encore
exister à paris qui compte un million de
voitures ce sont les automobilistes qui
devrait s'étonner de pouvoir encore
circulé c'est entre les voitures de la
préfecture de police constitue autant d'
agences de renseignement pour le poste
centrale de commande véritable
dispatching de la circulation
[Musique]
le
un embouteillage et il signalé le poste
de commande qui dispose d'un plan
général de la signalisation va par
l'intermédiaire d'un jeu de contact
électronique changer le rythme des feux
de signalisation du secteur
[Musique]
mieux encore sur un itinéraire donné une
[ __ ] enregistre le flot des voitures
et communique automatiquement les
renseignements au poste central celui ci
modifie en conséquence les temps d'arrêt
sur l'itinéraire en fonction du trafic
c'est ainsi que paris possède malgré
tout la circulation la plus rapide du
monde
souvent il est plus facile de circuler
que de stationner dans certaines zones
les zones bleues la durée du
stationnement est limité à une heure
mais c'était compter sans le système p
le déplacement de voitures a fait son
apparition sur les champs elysées
[Musique]
toutes les airs il déplace la voiture de
ses abonnés et le tour paraît jouer mais
attention le fichier central des
contraventions a été doté d'un système
de classement automatique qui classent
également les récidivistes et il y en a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]